As you all know, the
Opposition Media Network
is the leader in exposing the
lies that exist all around us.
But I can't do all the exposing
by myself here at this desk.
That's why I have
citizen-journalists
who go out into the world
and expose themselves.
(audience whooping)
They also cover stories.
Two of them
recently did just that--
Josh Sharp and Aaron Jackson.
-Guys.
-(cheering, applause)
You went out into the field into
some pretty dicey territory.
Yeah, the diciest, Jordan.
This past weekend, there was
a big lefty march in DC
called the March
for Racial Justice.
Now, as we all know, liberals
don't believe in anything,
which is why they have
to be paid to show up.
So we decided
to go and blow the lid
off these walking jars
of hypocrisy.
-Ooh, nice metaphor.
-I've been practicing metaphor.
Yeah, it shows.
It really shows.
We were ready, Jordan,
and a little scared,
but we had to see this nefarious
left-wing operation up close.
Roll it!
♪ ♪
SHARP:
For the last year,
Trump has been plowing
our country into greatness,
yet we're seeing
heated protests
from the violent left.
So what's behind it?
A lot of these, uh,
people that protest
are professional agitators.
We know for a fact
that they were paid.
I'd like to see George Soros
stop funding the organizations.
Anytime there is
violent protests...
...bought and paid for
by the Hillary campaign,
the Democrat Party
or George Soros...
JACKSON: That's right,
the left pays their protestors.
Even our president
knows the truth.
That's why we were disgusted
when we saw
Amazon's Washington Post
promote
the DC Local Ambassadors,
a group that actually helps
organize people for marches.
The whole thing stank of Soros.
Could they be his pawns?
We went to find out.
Sure, we'd love to hang out in
front of Trump Tower all day,
but we have a job to do:
infiltrating the violent left.
Now, we figured out
that their headquarters
are located in an art gallery,
so we're gonna go there...
-(gags)
-You okay?
-No, I'm fine. It's just art.
-Right.
-I'm fine.
-Come on.
So to make sure that we can
go there undetected,
we will be deep undercover
as liberals.
♪ ♪
(cheering and applause)
-I think this is it.
-Here we are.
Let's just give a little, um...
(clears throat)
Hello.
SHARP: There she was.
The mastermind
behind this terrifying
training ground.
-We came with...
-We came with gifts.
-Oh, lovely.
-So these cookies are vegan.
-Cookies. -This a tote bag
full of tote bags.
-Just full of other totes.
-Come on in.
SHARP:
We were in.
Now time to interrogate this
queenpin of chaos
in the adorable
beer garden next door.
We are a group of volunteers
that help support marches
and other events in Washington.
We help march organizers
with logistics, permitting,
um, basically all of the
different ingredients
to make sure that marches
go smoothly and are fun.
Like, we wanted to do
a march for, uh,
gender identity
and climate change,
'cause a lot of hurricanes are
boy names or girl names,
-and we want to give them
more gender fluid names. -Oh.
-Okay. -That's, you know,
hitting a lot of buttons.
-Mm-hmm. -Could there be a lot
of money for protestors
who wanted to come out
for that one?
-We don't pay protestors.
-SHARP: Mmm.
George Soros pays
the protestors.
I don't think
anyone pays protestors.
SHARP:
Did you hear that?
She said she thinks
they don't get paid.
And so we thinked
we had a lead.
-Come on, have a seat, guys.
-Oh. It's a real bummer.
-Welcome.
-So nice seeing you.
-Thank you.
-So good to see you.
SANDERS: I'm really glad to see
so many new faces.
We're always looking
for new volunteers.
Tonight we're working
particularly
on the March for Racial Justice.
Your team leader
will give you a call
a couple of days before
the march,
and make sure you know where
to show up, what to wear,
-basic things like that.
-SHARP: I'm sorry.
Uh, baseball bats,
are they provided?
Or is it BYOBB?
Baseball bats?
-Just for... when things...
-You know, for a protest.
Right.
Yeah, we say that,
but what happens happens.
And that's what happens
because we say it.
-Okay.
-Until we do.
-No. -No, we don't.
-Gotcha. Gotcha.
SHARP: They were clearly
stonewalling us,
but we pressed on.
The next step in their
indoctrination
was something called
de-escalation training.
JACKSON: In what sort of seemed
like an improv game,
we pretended to be
march organizers
standing their ground against
angry counter protestors.
You sound like a busy person,
you go ahead and do
whatever you want.
SHARP:
We clearly passed as liberals.
Our subtle and nuanced
portrayal had fooled them all.
What went well in that scenario?
Um, I liked using that tactic
that we learned, um,
-to gang-up on somebody and, um,
-MAN: That wasn't one of them.
and oppress them.
SHARP: They accepted us
as two of their own.
Now it was time for the most
dangerous part of our mission:
Going to one of their
organized marches,
and exposing Soros' shady plot.
♪ ♪
I've got a few volunteers
for you to check-in.
-Hello. Thank you.
-Hi. Salutation. -Welcome.
-This-this piece of paper
you keep with you. -Okay.
It's if you should trip and fall
or faint or something.
-Worker's comp. -And we need--
No. Not workmen's comp.
SHARP: Now that we were dressed
as figures of authority,
they would have to tell us
who was paying them.
I don't need to be paid
to stand up for the obvious,
what's obviously right,
what is inherently right.
That's ridiculous.
People get to come and see
others, like-minded people,
who-who have nothing but love
in their heart
for people, um, who may
look different from them.
SHARP:
All day they lied to us,
claiming they cared about
the issues,
when we knew they must be there
for the cash.
Why wouldn't they tell us the
truth we already believed?
And that's when it hit us.
JACKSON:
Prop signs, musical numbers,
the damn improv games?
These people weren't just
nobodies off the street
paid to hold signs,
they were actors.
Deep in character,
and masters of their craft.
SHARP:
Just like us.
There was only thing
left to do.
-Excuse me, sir. Sir.
-(indistinct chanting)
-Are you an actor?
-No.
SHARP:
Damn. That's some good acting.
Actor, actor, method, method.
-That's a scene right there.
-That's a scene.
-Actor.
-All of them off book.
I don't see a single script,
no sides.
Child actor.
You're a child actor.
SHARP: These method actors
never broke.
Clearly, they lived every day
as passionate citizens
who wanted to strengthen our
democracy through civic action.
JACKSON:
The performance of a lifetime.
And that's coming from two of
the best actors around.
Wow.
Impressive undercover stuff,
guys.
Josh and Aaron, everyone.